I'm going to let you explore that code we just looked at on your own
during the project portion of this lesson.
There's just one more thing I want to cover though before I set you
loose on that.
And that is how to think about selecting how many principal components you
should look at.
In that last example,
they went from 1850 features on the input to 150 principal components.
And the question you might be wondering is,
how did they come up with that number?
It's a little bit tough to answer that, because there's no cut and
dry answer for how many principal components you should use.
You kind of have to figure it out.
Which of these options do you think sounds like a good way to figure out how
many principal components you should be using?
Here are your options.
The first one is, just always take the top 10%, as a rule of thumb.
A second option is that you can train on a different number of
principal components, and then see how the accuracy response for
each of those possible numbers of principal components.
And then, once you do this several times, it will become clear that there
is a point of diminishing returns where as you add more principal components,
you don't get much more in terms of discrimination.
And that you should cut off once you start to plateau.
And the third option is that you could perform feature selection on the input
features before you put them into PCA, and then you just use as many principal
components as you had from input features after you've performed that selection.